a short while ago we made a number file
video about a problem to do with
different time equations and whether
numbers can be written as a sum of three
cubes we still don't know an answer to
that one so we've not yet been able to
find any integers which when we sum up
their cubes
since then we've had some breaking news
so there's a paper
that's appeared and um someone has
actually gone away and uh
this guy sander hussman has gone away
and calculated a new solution to one
integer that was previously unknown
whether it was a sum of three cubes or
not well indeed he credits the number
file video he sort of found that it was
kind of interesting enough to just have
a go at pushing the boundaries of
knowledge a little bit further and and
he managed to sort of get this going on
a computer search and i think he was
searching for
something like 12.5 cpu years on a bank
of computers in leon and was able to
find a new solution for the number 74.
so we are interested in suppose that
we're given an integer k can you find
integers x y
and z
and these can be both positive and
negative such that x cubed plus y cubed
plus z cubed is equal to k if we just
look at all of the integers between 1
and 99 as of last time there were only
three integers
on that list for which we didn't have an
answer about whether they could be
written as a sum of three cubes or not
and those were
33 42
and 74. now we know that this last
number here 74
is actually represented as a sum of
three cubes let me write it down for you
of course so here we go so 74 is now
known to be equal to minus 2 8 4 6 5 0 2
2 5 5 5 8 8 5 all cube
plus 6 6 2 two nine eight three two one
nine oh five five six you plus two eight
three four five 0 1 0 5 6 9 7 7 2 7 q
and there's the new solution he also
found some new solutions for larger
values of k but kind of the interesting
thing is for k less than 100 we now only
have two more numbers to worry about
here
the number 33 and the number 42.
and are they solvable are they are they
out there like is this a is this should
other people be firing up their
computers well absolutely so so far
thanks to sander we now know that if
we're interested in the number 33
there are certainly no solutions in
which the size of x y and z
are bounded by 10 to the 15. so that's a
pretty big range so you're going to have
to look further than that who knows it
may well be that if you just look up to
10 to the 16 you'll find a solution
and 42 do we know any more about that or
no nothing about that it's not
earth-shattering news i mean we thought
for a long time that these things do
have solutions in fact we think that
there are infinitely many solutions for
each of these values of k our
expectation is that they are very very
sparse so you might come across one and
then the next time you come across
another one might be
many many years down the line before
you've got computers enough to big
enough to find them
so i mean it's gratifying that this is
kind of uh coinciding with our belief
that these things do indeed have
solutions but in terms of sort of
fundamental mathematics that's gone into
this i would say that's not the case
it's kind of just a more extensive
computer search
not every number file viewer is going to
make a contribution like sander but the
people you see listed on the screen have
helped us out they're among our patreon
supporters and we really appreciate it
if you'd like to join their ranks with
no matter how small a contribution you
can go to patreon.com numberphile i'll
put a link in the video description
and by the way you can see on the screen
at the moment a link to our original
video which inspired sanders
investigation but we've also got a new
video and that's all about those values
of k
for which it's impossible to find a
solution not even sand is going to find
one for that
and if you'd like to see the proof
we've just put it on number file 2 and
by the way while you're over on number
numberphile 2 why not subscribe to the
channel because i don't always mention
it here and you might occasionally
stumble over something you didn't even
know existed